miles about to fire it halfway down the  floor  and lavello watch it hopefully he is  okay  only guy in the league who takes out  four chairs and a water cooler  and still smiles  that's a lot of disinfectants gonna have  to be used  at halftime who else laughs when they do  that that's incredible  eight three-pointers here ball  wow the mellow ball  i mean he really tried to make it he  tried to make that that that's what's  going to happen you're going to have to  sacrifice yourself  one more look you're going down taking  out the cards  see that's a 19 year old for you right  there 33 34.  yeah you're like make a different  decision  i see where sacramento